We're almost done, and you know what that means?
It's time for the doggy bag.
(barking)
There he goes.
And today it's a book that I simply can't put down.
The Anthropocene reviewed by John Green.
It's on all the best seller lists.
And I actually got to interview him when I
co-hosted CBS this morning.
And that was what turned me on to the book.
It's so fun.
Now, Anthropocene is how our human actions
impact the planet,
but don't think that it's a downer of a book.
It's actually the exact opposite.
It's John Green's take on all these different things he's
experienced in life and it's full of nostalgia and cute
charming stories and wisdom.
And he actually gives all of these things in life,
a five star review.
So they, each chapter ends in this really cute way.
Like how many stars is he going to give?
A certain thing.
I, I love this book.
I'm going to steal this one.
That copies for you, Roxy.
All right. Well, thank you so much everybody
for coming today. This was so fun.
(cheering)
And everybody watching at home,
we're so honored to see you. Have a fantastic day.
We hope you take
this with you.